there are sort of like um obscure
anti-vaxx people that have died during
the pandemic you know I'll mention to
you oh this uh you know Deputy County
Commissioner I don't even remember what
she was in California who went to an
anti-vaxx rally and posted some anti-vax
stuff on her Facebook she now died of
covet but typically most of those folks
are not like known to us and when
they're known to us they're often not
known as anti-vax people there's an
incredible new story which dozens of you
sent me over the weekend about a
Washington state police officer
who was sort of a celebrity anti-vaxxer
this was not an obscure random officer
Robert Lemay
quit his job as a Washington state
trooper because he didn't want to get
vaccinated during his sign off which we
will look at he told the Governor Jay
Inslee to kiss his ass he was on Fox
News being interviewed by Laura Ingram
as if he was some kind of hero for
quitting over the vaccine mandate he's
dead of covet
he's dead of covet state trooper who
told Governor to kiss my ass over
vaccine mandate dies of covet 19. this
is from two days ago Robert Lemay 51
famously signed off in his squad car
after 22 years of service in October
just a few months ago while blasting
Democratic Governor Jay Inslee the
governor had mandated state workers get
vaccinated against covet not unique to
the state of Washington Lemay died on
Friday here is his principled and
defiant sign off where he also sends a
shot across the bow at the Governor Jay
Inslee wish I could say more but um this
is it so State 1034 this is the last
time you'll hear me in a state patrol
car and James leaking just passed
wow what a principled and defiant action
that this guy took
um once again he was also known to the
Fox News Community here he is being
interviewed by Laura Ingram and getting
a hero's welcome this was in October
right around the time that he did this
uh stun
oh
check they were
weren't the vaccination staff the Border
when we had
the people waved in and one you know a
two-week period so they don't seem too
concerned about that Robert uh what's
next for you other than being a
celebrity now what's next for you yeah
other than catching covet and dying
right
you know so I'm overwhelmed um I really
am I'm a pretty private person
um and um my son's in the military I'm
like son this is what's happening he
goes all right Dad I'm going black
um so it's we're just trying to put our
feet on the ground I mean it's funny
we're we're very religious people and we
prayed about all this when this first
started you know Lord what do you want
us to do and notice that the prayer did
not save him from covid and that's uh
the again
oh is did he not pray correctly did he
not pray hard enough did he do other
things wrong so that God did not answer
his prayers because for all the prayer
he died of covet it's our path and
um we've had applications out of state
and all types of stuff but Lord never
really pointed us to one point so we
said okay maybe this is the fight well
then that came out and it went viral and
I'm like okay this is where you want us
to do right now so I'm the spokesperson
for thousands and thousands I even say
millions of people I think there's two
million people that have actually viewed
it
um it's been 99 positive from everybody
um I think this is my path right now um
there's a lot of job offers that I'm
getting phenomenal job offers all right
well I'm a sleeping giant yeah well
maybe a sleep a sleeping giant all right
so and there uh Laura Ingram Cuts him
off she's had enough of it so what was
next for Robert Lemay was catching covet
on vaccinated and dying and of course as
I've said before we we can't say for
sure about any end of visual he would
have survived had he been vaccinated we
can't we you can't ever say that about a
particular person
statistically because the vaccines are
so effective at preventing serious
illness and death all those great job
offers that he was getting all of this
celebrity welcome and all of the he
would have been able to carry it out had
he just been vaccinated but of course
had he been vaccinated he never would
have become the anti-vaxx hero in the
first place the takeaway here guys is
this is a cautionary tale we're not
dancing on his grave the the cautionary
tale is no matter how Brazen your
rhetoric is no matter how alpha you
believe yourself or others believe you
to be because of your job or because of
your physical appearance or whatever
covid might kill you and so we have one
tool that really reduces the odds of
that and it's the vaccine this guy chose
to forego it it was because of his
prayer to God not because of Any valid
medical reason or anything else he has
now died of covet celebrity anti-backs
cop who told Jay Inslee to kiss his ass
is dead and he will not be working any
of those other jobs we'll take a quick
break and be right back
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple people are busy
we're not always getting effective
balanced nutrition from the food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality
bioavailable ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple I've been enjoying
the ag1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good helps me get everything I'm trying
to get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athletic greens.com Pacman the link is
in the podcast notes